es sind extrem seltsame signale die da
vom stern ross 128 aufgefangen wurden
danke für den themenvorschlag amtiert
als erstes schießen natürlich auch die
gedanken an aliens in den kopf und das
auch bei den wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen die es entdeckt
haben sind es also ähnliche signale
oder was ist dabei frost 128 los geht's
endlich zum seitenwechsel herzlich
willkommen
am 15 august 77 wurde das signal aus dem
sternbild schütze empfangen
es war breit ich mal stärker als das
hintergrundrauschen im weltall noch
heute ist unklar woher stammt wer es
gewendet hat oder welchen ursprungs hat
einiges spricht dafür dass es
tatsächlich der versuch einer
kontaktaufnahme war wie auch wir sie
schon bereits vom arecibo radioteleskop
am 16 november 1974 aus gesendet haben
die idee hatte der aktuell sicher frank
drake wer auch die drake formel
entwickelt hat mit ihr kann man
ausrechnen wieviele außerirdische
zivilisationen sich in einer galaxie
befinden aber das hatten wir letztlich
beim thema dass wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen tatsächlich eine
alien-invasion befürchten wenn wir
weiter so sorglos signale in den welt
kommen wenden aber jetzt hat das
vielleicht eine andere spezies gemacht
es war im zwölften mai dieses jahres
als die wissenschaftler des arecibo
telescope sehr seltsame signale auf
fliegen also genau dem teleskop das 1974
die botschaft an aliens aussendete zehn
minuten war teleskop auf den stern einen
roten zwerg ross 128 ausgerichtet da war
empfing er signale die zitat aus
breitband pulsen die nicht polarisiert
waren und bargeld rios wiederholten
bestanden so edel männer vom arecibo
radioteleskop aber was ist das für ein
signal sofort sprechen alle über aliens
und außerirdische signale
doch auch wenn er selbst den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sofort durch den kopf
schief zuerst gibt es zahlreiche andere
möglichkeiten da werden zum beispiel er
also strahlungs ausbrüche des stern wie
bei uns auf der sonne
allerdings wären dann die frequenzen 4
niedriger und die streuung der signale
passt nicht möglichkeit zwei eine
falsche zuordnung der signale aber es
gibt keine objekte in richtung von ross
128 die solche signale aussenden können
also auch nicht stören pulse satelliten
allerdings nehmen die nicht solche
signale ab also auch wusste gruppen ja
also doch signale von außen wir haben
hier ein mysterium jede der drei
erklärung ist im moment so gut oder so
schlecht wie jeder andere das sagt
mendes aber so mendes das heißt noch
nicht dass seine ideen signal sein muss
und auch verschoss weg vom wti projektes
ist das projekt wo nach außerirdischen
signalen gesucht wird der held erst mal
den ball flach keine bestätigung es
gibt noch zahlreiche andere
möglichkeiten sowie so ist es eher ein
störsignal
von der erde im moment sieht das aber
eher anders aus und wenn es so
weitergeht bleibt am ende keine
erklärung und dann wäre wiederum ein
alien signal
die wahrscheinlichste am 16 juli haben
die forscherinnen und forscher jetzt
nochmal das archiv ibo radioteleskop und
sieben weitere teleskope auf 128
ausgerichtet zurzeit wird ausgewertet
und wir werden euch natürlich darüber
hier auf dem laufenden halten falls er
das ergebnis also nicht verpassen wollte
dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glaube
hier geht es weiter mit dem schon
erwähnten video alien invasion durch
nachricht an außerirdische wirklich
eine sehr spannende diskussion in der
wissenschaft wenn es euch interessiert
unbedingt braucht klicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleib dran